it's finally here the objectively best
holiday of the year
today Halloween is celebrated all around
the world there are jack-o'-lanterns
everywhere people are dressed in
costumes and go trick-or-treating and as
always people find another excuse to get
drunk Halloween has some pretty strong
characteristics and rituals but where
does all this come from what are the
origins of this beloved holiday and
where does some of the creatures
strongly associated with it come from
strap yourselves in put that drink down
seriously you need help and I might just
tell you
[Music]
most people scholars included agree that
Halloween at least to some degree has
origins in the old pagan Celtic festival
called Sauron it was celebrated in the
Ireland region before the arrival of
Christianity and took place between the
evening of October 31st and November 1st
much like our modern Halloween it was
believed that this date had spiritual
significance that on this day the portal
or sort of bridge between our world and
the next was blurred or open so that
creatures from the other side could
enter our world many different rituals
appear to have been performed at this
festival including lighting bonfires but
we're not really sure what these were
for or what they signified in fact it
should be remembered that much of what
we know today about Sawin was written
down long after the arrival of
Christianity and there isn't a lot in
the ways of written material that exists
from before this time so it is possible
that a lot of the information is altered
or even fabricated but we can be pretty
sure that this is a festival that did
take place and that some of these
rituals were performed however people
also tend to overemphasize the role that
saw and played on our modern holiday of
Halloween much of it still remain like
the date October 31st and - something we
also its focus on ghosts and monsters
and death but much of what we know as
Halloween is actually made up of a
myriad of different Christian European
traditions that would be implemented
much later the most significant and most
recognizable of these are the Christian
holidays of All Saints Day and All Souls
Day celebrated still to this day in some
European countries for example here in
Sweden we celebrate Halloween and All
Saints Day separately Halloween on
October 31st and All Saints Day on the
first Saturday of Nova
now All Saints Day is a festival of
remembrance for the Saints of
Christianity and all souls day is the
festival of remembrance for people who
have recently departed this world in
general much similar to the Mexican
festival Day of the Dead particularly in
Western Europe these twin holidays were
often celebrated around October 31st
probably as a way of appropriating the
already existing holiday of sovereign
and thus gain converts and the impact
this festival had on modern Halloween is
significant in fact historian dr.
Nicholas Rogers writes that while Cerwyn
may have been the origin of the holiday
the rituals we associate with it have
very little connection and that quote
most of these rituals developed in
conjunction with a medieval holy days of
All Souls and All Saints Day this
includes the name itself Halloween which
stems from All Hallows Eve signifying
the day before All Hallows day or All
Saints Day as well as the wearing of
costumes which appeared around the 16th
century furthermore trick-or-treating
may have origins in a practice called
soling where people went from door to
door asking for prayers for the dead
clearly then these Christian holidays
had a major impact on the modern holiday
of Halloween which shows you that its
history is very complex and multifaceted
it is true that it has its origins in
the pagan festivals Sawin but very
little of that connection remained today
for most people Halloween is a day of
partying eating candy dressing up and
watching horror films I at least very
strongly associate Halloween with some
of our most famous pop culture monsters
like Dracula Frankenstein's monster and
and werewolves and the story of these
characters is pretty interesting as well
the story of dr. Frankenstein and the
monster that he creates is one of the
most famous horror stories in the world
the movie starring Boris Karloff and the
appearance that he created is so itched
into our culture
but it's almost impossible to imagine
any other version but the original story
is actually quite different and has a
very strong message the book
Frankenstein or the modern prometheus
was written by English author Mary
Shelley in the early 19th century the
story is familiar to most of you the
scientist dr. Frankenstein wants to
create life he Rob's the graves of dead
people takes their body parts stitches
together a person and then attempts to
make it live amazingly he succeeds but
as soon as he reaches his goal he's
horrified with his own creation and
leaves him the rest of the story deals
with the monster and the pain he has to
go through being scared and isolated
without anyone to love or care for him
he's seen by everyone including his own
creator as a monster obviously this is a
very tragic and sad story and much of
this doesn't really carry over that much
to the film version more so actually in
the sequel called the Bride of
Frankenstein but nonetheless the
important part in message here is of
course that the monster isn't the
villain at all but dr. Frankenstein
himself is as well as the people who
sort of chase him and considering to be
a monster the original novel was written
in a period known as Romanticism or the
Romantic era that took place for about
the first half of the 19th century this
was an artistic intellectual and
literary period there was a strong
reaction against the period of
enlightenment that prevailed during the
preceding century the Enlightenment
period put all its emphasis on science
and rationality it rationalized
everything including nature which a lot
of people felt was inadequate
romanticism instead as a reaction to
this considers strong emotions as a
valuable aesthetic experience and
considered this to be more important
than
to rationality in a sense and so
Frankenstein or the modern prometheus is
the quintessential gothic novel of the
Romantic era because it deals with
exactly these questions the book is a
strong comment and critique of these so
excessive rationalism and scientist of
the time
dr. Frankenstein in his quest to create
life completely abandons all ethics he
cares only about whether or not he can
do it and doesn't care at all about the
creature that he actually creates he is
as Ian Malcolm says in Jurassic Park
we're so preoccupied with whether or not
they could did you stop to think they
should and this is characteristic of the
debate that this book finds itself in do
we let scientific progress compromise
our humanity are we too busy thinking
about whether or not we can that we
forget whether or not we should know
this is a theme that also carries over
to a lot of other literature for example
as I mentioned the Jurassic Park
franchise has very much the same message
throughout Mary Shelley in her book
warns against this kind of behavior dr.
Frankenstein is as we say playing God
and she wants us not to fall into that
same trap now another famous monsters of
course the werewolf of course one of the
most famous classic movie monsters is
the Wolfman
werewolves are humans that can
shape-shift into wolves and there have
been throughout history cases of
werewolf executions that is people who
are accused and tried of being
werewolves and then executed for it
much like the more famous witch trials
the origins of the werewolf myth is
difficult to know for sure it could have
been a way of dealing with serial
killers or livestock being killed by
actual wolves
some people even speculate that this had
something to do with a message against
so called interspecies sex that is that
you are not supposed to have sex with
animals in any case the werewolf has
been a very significant part of our
culture and history throughout
world and is today a very familiar
character especially in connection with
the holiday like Halloween and a lot of
those classic horror films but perhaps
my favorite creature that I associate
with Halloween is Dracula and the
vampire the vampire is an undead person
that sucks the blood of the living for
nourishment in many cases the vampire
can turn into a bat but this connection
hasn't always existed vampires have
existed particularly in European
folklore for hundreds of years if not
even longer and have taken on many
different forms as time went by the
Uniting characteristic being that they
all suck blood for nourishment and that
they are Undead in fact the classic or
should I say modern vampire was born in
the 19th century in 1819 John William
Polydorus novel the vampire was
published which is considered by many to
be the first to create a coherent genre
of vampire fiction later that century
though in 1897 the Irish author Bram
Stoker would release what is probably
the most significant novel ever for our
modern conception of vampires
he called it Dracula this classic
character vampire of vampires Dracula
was actually partly based on a real-life
person a ruler in Transylvania in the
15th century called Vlad the 3rd Dracula
more commonly known as Vlad the Impaler
it is said that Vlad killed upwards of a
hundred thousand people throughout his
reign and very characteristically he had
his enemies executed by impaling them
legend says that Vlad would sit at his
dinner table and eats as people were
brutally impaled in front of him a kind
of dinner entertainment if you will the
name Dracula actually comes from the
Romanian word that ah cool which means
the dragon Bram Stoker kept the name and
the location Transylvania but also took
a lot of influences from a European
folklore and a lot of other sort of vamp
our stories to create the most famous
vampire of all time in his novel Dracula
became a well-spoken pale man who could
turn into a bat crawl on walls couldn't
be seen in mirrors hates garlic and many
of those classic characteristics that we
know and love all these stories and
monsters are strongly associated with
Halloween and really makes it what it is
in other words Halloween is like a
melting pot of a myriad of different
influences and traditions from the pagan
festival of Sauron to the Christian
holidays of All Saints in our souls day
and finally to our modern pop culture
references like the classic horror films
and the monsters to year the episodes of
our favorite TV shows like The Simpsons
and their treehouse of horror and many
of these other influences that have come
about in the last hundred years or 200
years you could say that Halloween is
both very old and very new you can now
resume your celebrations go
trick-or-treating dress up and watch a
horror film but don't forget to stop for
a second and think about death and the
way it affects our lives it's always
going to be there but that doesn't have
to be a negative thing happy Halloween
everyone and I'll see you soon